a fuel tanker crash started a fire that
caused a portion of Interstate 95 to
collapse over the weekend the national
Transportation safety board is sending a
team in to investigate and local
officials are worried that it may be
gridlocked for months Chris Van Cleave
has a story and some astonishing video
[Music]
thriving through an inferno early Sunday
morning a gasoline tanker crashed under
an I-95 overpass in Philadelphia
sparking a fire so hot it brought part
of the freeway Crashing Down
Pennsylvania's Governor says it appears
at least one vehicle is still in the
rubble we're still working to identify
any individual or individuals who may
have been caught in the fire and the
collapse Frank Graber was returning from
the airport when he took these pictures
approaching the Flames two cars ahead of
me went through the fire so I just
floored it and drove through as he drove
across the smoke-filled overpass he said
he felt the road Buckle underneath him I
stood a drop like a roller coaster so I
was like well it wasn't very smart
because I could have fell right in the
fire the collapse section of I-95
handles roughly 160 000 Vehicles a day a
very very heavily traveled Interstate
one that's now closed in both directions
indefinitely for Miles creating a
traffic nightmare
the collapsed overpass was part of a 212
million dollar reconstruction project
that just finished four years ago today
Governor Josh Shapiro plans to make a
disaster declaration to speed up funds
for a rebuilding effort he warns could
take months for CBS mornings I'm Chris
Van Cleave